they
[Music]
studies
[Music]
and you know he's playing the game well
but you know they should have never gone
before and we've got a rescue center
where they've been a things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so that's my question you want sorry
a couple of things I wanted to race as
well
then one
what would we actually important because
could we noticed instead of having
percentages we actually look for this
percentage
mean or what figure yeah because all
this is difficult percentage right
it's good to the point
right okay it was it was longer
reviewing the qbr that's what members
asked for was percentages so that's what
why we then we call percentages
at the end of the day if you could you
know what is what is 50 percent of it
100 is it 220 000 or whatever it means
facts of nothing
[Music]
[Music]
and then
it's it's just a multitude division that
I realized
but I mean the 541 outstanding is
part of this goes back to 2015.
you know and I know that I know that how
important but okay a good people to make
sure that
episode
I think this is kind of a
misunderstanding about how how they say
the chief Progressive
holiday we're talking about negotiation
and we have to negotiate Festival
um we can't just go in and take in the
important action the reason being for
that is is the ramifications of the
enforcement action are uh criminal
sanctions so if we didn't and when it
seems to be reasonable then it would be
um anyway the other part of the club
learning through some of these cases is
the fact that once an appeal is
submitted we have to speak the important
action pending the outcome of that field
and these appeals
can take a long time to come to fruition
I mean 18 months two years
um
will expedite some of them but in a name
about sounding so the wedding
might be the reason now we've got no
choices about
um we have to kind of comply
um and some of these feelings have been
told by a few patient by negotiating
with people
um and I think as a whole I think Amazon
the public would prepare for us to
negotiate and not go if there's a
negotiation that that can be achieved we
did prosecute we have prosecuted but the
powers that we have within the
legislation aren't quite slim so even if
we do prosecute that doesn't resolve the
bridge it doesn't mean for example in
the buildings of penultimate and that's
unauthorized that the results of that
prosecution is to remove it it is just
differential usually usually the
financial penalty and and in the main
that's why you're looking for playing
negotiate because the prosecution is
just a telemarketing
there's a lot
members of the public right come to the
likes of me to do the reporting because
they don't want to because it's their
next door neighbor you understand and
and this is
but yeah I mean yeah
they don't want to be seen to be doing
anything
and that's yeah
[Music]
um but anyway
that's all but I think the questions and
answers
um
nobody else what I'm saying here
we'll move on
consideration of the plot forward
foreign
[Music]
just check my emails they've come
through they've just been published so
people want to go online and have a look
it's all online now and you can actually
search by local Authority and some some
uh information out otherwise so I'm
happy to bring the report back in
December if that's what then
strategies
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
because we have the Strategic plans
with experience with that covered so it
may be not as look at that as we have
planned please
[Music]
we um well obviously that's kind of
along with the qbr that up the
non-financial bits of the TBR because
you've got all the actions in that the
other areas from the strap act so they
are preparing marrying each other
there's also a an overarching
strathcland delivery plan that holds uh
period of Retribution anyway
for the detail you can get it from Who
We Are
you've got all the actions in the queue
in the trackpad in your PVR anyway it's
there and that's what it's there
right in the first one that makes sense
so
forward uh
the legs
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
all right got anybody out there yes
[Music]
right okay
um